remember kelly clarkson's rendition of  dolly parton's i will always love you at  last week's acm awards well now dolly is  sharing her thoughts on it calling it  one of the best ever as she appeared  virtually on the kelly clarkson show to  promote her new book with james  patterson take a look and we'll see you  next time  i have to say again it was great to sing  your music last week at the academy  country music awards but i will say it's  always  always always going to be terrifying to  sing your song in front of you while  you're there just so you know i'm always  sweating profusely  oh well i mean i don't think you'd have  to worry with a voice like yours i was  so honored and nobody can sing like you  so i was very proud of you and so proud  of your rendition of it is great one of  the best ever  ever you are so kind